foreign
okay
so i want to show you guys
okay so i have two lives going here so
i'm gonna be talking to like two cameras
um because i'm going live on tick tock
and
um youtube but basically i wanted to
talk to you guys about a video that i'm
making um
on
youtube it's gonna be a youtube video
but i might post clips
on tick tock and it's basically talking
about this pickup conference that i went
to um maybe boot camp is a better word
um
so i'm like gonna talk about my
experience and what i learned
so i'm gonna show you guys what i have
i don't know i thought it might be a fun
like experiment to see how involving
like my audience would go with like
making my youtube and tiktok videos
so
okay pickup conference yeah okay so this
is how i'm gonna start it so
i'm gonna make kind of clickbaity i'm
gonna go i went to a pickup con or um a
pickup boot camp i know what you're
thinking so um hold on i might like type
and talk like sometimes i get a thought
and i just want to
i went to a pickup
boot camp
i know what you're thinking what you're
thinking
thinking what is a pickup boot camp
a pickup boot camp
um
what is a pickup
boot camp
and why on earth were you there
you there
so
um
a pickup boot camp
is where
people go where people mostly men i'm
going to say
mostly men go to a location for a couple
of days and are taught basically how to
get laid
right
basically
um
i got a lot of questions with this one
why did what boot camp did i go to and
why
why would you go
um do you think they're manipulating
women i don't know i'm gonna do like um
we're trying to do get a pick up for
your man or what no
no okay so that that's how i'm gonna
start the video so
my goal in going to the boot camp and i
have to think about how i'm gonna like
phrase this it's like honestly i'm nosy
i'm like nosy as hell
so i just went to the boot camp because
i wanted to know what
like
i just wanted to like understand how
guys think and like
i just wanna and i thought it'd be a
good youtube video honestly like just
learning about
how what got like how guys think
and like what tricks or whatever they
use to get girls i don't know who you
are i'm gonna subscribe thank you
thank you
um
i don't know how i can see on
this like how many people are on my tick
tock but
i can't even tell if anyone's in here
but
okay anyways i'm talking more to my
youtube just because there's more people
on or commenting at least
okay so
so first i'm going to talk about like
why did i pick
um why i picked john anthony lifestyle
so
first i want to say
you know um i've seen like mixed reviews
on him some people say that he is a scam
artist some people say that he
is um
like knows what he's talking about and
um this is the reason the reason i
picked it was i can't
speak for if he's living his life
authentically i have no idea but
um he lives with like three hot models
right
and everyone says they're like hookers
but i'm like what kind of hooker like
lives with you that would be like that
would be a lot like that'd be kind of
hard
like to pull off and she like has an
engineering job
like
could be right sugar babies yeah you
know fair enough um
but
anyways i'm gonna continue
um he just seemed to have more proof
than anyone else in the manosphere
like a lot of the guys that give like
dating advice like don't have like a
girl on their arms and john anthony
doesn't really um
like promote relationships so i don't
think like
him having a girl on his arm really is
that important but what was more
important was i just saw a lot of proof
like
on his channel when it came to like
sleeping with different girls and like
hooking up with different girls like
more proof than anyone else has provided
so
yeah that that's why i picked him
i i can't and okay in the second reason
so that's what i was going to talk about
like the first half
um and then the second part of that as i
was going to say
um his system made sense to me um so i
worked a sales background and like one
of the things that he talked about and i
saw a video on this
um
is
like overcoming like girls objections
and like making girls feel comfortable
and a lot of the stuff that he said i
was like oh
like i could see
like i i could see like from a sales
perspective like i could understand his
thinking and it just like made sense to
me
so
um when am i going live on instagram i
went live on instagram like yesterday or
two days ago no yesterday
but
okay
so any other
questions from there that like you guys
would want
i mean i'm like butchering it obviously
it's gonna be a lot more
clean i guess
okay i'm looking at my tick tock so i'm
on live on two different lives so that's
why i like look one way and then like
the other
um i'm making a video about a pickup
conference that i went to which is
basically where guys pay to like learn
how to like
get girls
like pretty much
okay
who do i listen to music wise um
country
one is in the states i'm in um england
right now
okay so
the next part of the video would be
um
how i set up the video so i would talk
about my goal was i really wanted to
bring a guy that had really little and
um
little to no experience with women right
did i go to learn how to get girls i
mean sort of uh
i just i'm nosy i wanted to know what
the guys were talking about
um
but so i brought that was my goal i
wanted to bring a guy that had like
didn't really get girls had no
experience with girls
um
and
and like just you know see how it goes
for him
unfortunately i couldn't find a guy to
go that like wanted to learn um
yeah like i i could not for the life of
me
so i found a guy but he already like was
pretty successful with women like he
told me he'd slept with like over
i remember if he said over 50 or over
100 people but his body count was like
pretty high
so
it was kind of random like i went to
visit my friend and then
it was like someone she knew sue so we
just like started talking about
different pickup and like the manosphere
that sort of stuff
and i ended up like inviting him and he
ended up coming
i know that's what i was saying i want i
really wanted to bring a guy that had
like no experience with women but
i just couldn't figure it out anyways um
that's lifetime high
yeah i guess it depends the manuscript
is kind of weird
okay
so then the next part of the video
i wanted to talk about
so this is like what we did
four to five well i don't think they
were all his girlfriends
um okay so we all met up in the hotel
before going out for the night i was a
little nervous because i
am i get no i'm not gay
i have a boyfriend
um okay we all met up in the hotel room
before going out for the night i was a
little nervous because i felt like the
guys were gonna be really awkward or
weird because i was like the only girl
and i just i was like the type of guys
that go to this have to be super
socially awkward
um
first thing i noticed was like the guys
were more normal than i thought they
would be um
i don't think any of the guys there were
like crazy smooth talkers or crazy like
like
like there was maybe one or two guys
that was like super awkward but
like for them like the most of them i
would just say were regular guys like i
was just expecting like
like extreme awkwardness
because i was like what kind of guy like
pays thousands of dollars to go to a
boot camp
apparently normal guys i guess
um
okay
um so we met up before going out
and what the first thing that i noticed
this thing that i noticed i noticed was
a lot of what they taught was just
confidence
confidence
having
the confidence
to go up to women
to women so basically we would go to
like a nightclub or like a bar or
something and the guys would just like
and we would go
go
[Music]
a nightclub or bar
and the guys would
just approach
women
and the coaches would give them feedback
feedback so for example
um
any advice for someone that wants to
play volleyball for the first time uh
how old are you because that would
change the advice that i would give you
um okay
so
for example
um
one piece of advice
of advice um they give
is to break the touch barrier
so you can't be confident you can't
you can't
show a girl you're confident
confident in your own body
in your own body
if you're
if you're like too afraid to touch her
and not in like a weird way hold on
okay wait um
touch her not in like a weird way either
um
just like you know
small of her back arm whatever it is
another example of something
of something where did i move to i moved
to east london okay you're 24 and you've
never played if you've never played
volleyball
i would tell you to find like a league
and look for like i'm guessing it's c or
d
um because that's like
that's like probably the level of play
and you won't be the only one that's
like playing for the first time
read the room
before you touch anybody um
one piece of advice i kind of disagreed
with was ask for a kiss like don't be
afraid to ask for the kiss
um
um
that was like i was like i would be
weirded out if a guy asked me that like
right away but
some of them it like worked for so maybe
not um
um another piece of advice they would
give
a piece of advice
they would give
um was
i was okay if you have to ask them you
probably shouldn't okay i was surprised
by like
how many girls said yeah i guess if
if you like you can't
be successful if you don't ask so i was
surprised by like that worked on like
more girls than i thought it would so
um another piece of advice they would
give is
um approaching
i think it was like approaching from the
side instead of head on i can't remember
exactly this was a couple like this was
like two months ago
this was right before i left for england
i was so stressed before coming here i
did not have time for this video
okay so
this this this um
you wouldn't want me in my social sphere
what does that even mean
like
okay um okay so basically i would go to
a club and the guys would approach and
the coaches would give them feedback
that was the example of feedback that
they might give um
another example of feedback was not to
seem too friendly and get placed in the
friend zone like make sure you're still
like flirting with her don't just stay
like in the
um
okay
so day two came around
they've approach from the side
no it was
i can't remember this was so long ago so
i can't but it was like
either approach from the side or
approach from the front because one of
them is like
oh my god i can't remember
i can't remember and this is bothering
me i can't remember but
whatever like
i'll figure out which one they said
um okay so day two i was literally so
tired we were out until like four in the
morning just like approaching girls
and
so day two we went to a mall
and they would approach girls at the
mall um
it was actually fun i would be like go
approach them and then they'd like send
the guys like oh my god i had a blast i
had so much fun okay
um
um okay but like it was basically the
same thing just like at a mall and then
like same thing at night or like at a
club um
but okay so then like i don't i don't
think it's gonna be necessary and you
guys can let me know if you're
interested but like i don't think i'm
gonna go into that much detail about
like what um
what um
i had a black black what does that mean
oh my god the internet's so weird um
okay but
i don't think i'm going to go into that
much detail about like what exactly we
like did during the conference because
it was very repetitive like you go to a
day club
approach women go to a mall approach
women go to a club again approach like
it was just like approach approach
approach approach
talk to girls
um
but
so
okay so approaching
so these are some questions and let me
know in the comments like if you guys
had other questions um
like for the video because one was do i
think they're manipulating women um and
i would actually surprisingly say
no
i think that like women we actually
appreciate a lot of this stuff like guys
knowing this stuff we just like don't
know that we appreciate it um
i think like we appreciate a guy that
like knows how to talk to girls
um
but
i mean there's a couple things that kind
of made me like
not from the conference but just a
couple things i've seen on like youtube
or whatever
that was like like i don't like the hot
and cold like that sort of stuff um but
they didn't teach that at like the
pickup
um okay
most of the stuff that i saw like was
teaching guys to be more confident um um
i've never seen john personally promote
this but the only thing that hasn't sit
right with me in like
pickups pickup um was i don't like it
when they said um
they they would say like if a girl says
no to sex to like go back a step like if
she says no like you start taking off
her pants and she says no then to keep
like making out with her
and just keep like pushing it basically
until she says yes
um
that they didn't teach that at this boot
camp but like that that's like the only
thing in pickup that really like didn't
sit right with me because that's
like that's messed up clearly
um okay it reminded me a lot of sales um
a lot of times they're teaching the men
how to make women feel more comfortable
you don't believe in rape
yeah like basically
um okay
um
another thing i learned was it didn't
really matter
no matter how attractive the girl is the
girl was um
they would approach
approach unattractive and attractive
girls
and attractive girls
um okay i'm just gonna talk about how
the guys are more normal than you think
there was only like one or two that were
like pretty weird
but other most of them were like normal
i would say
um
do those okay so the instructors were
guys that like
basically like hooked up with different
girls like every single weekend and i
asked them i'm like do you guys
think you want to settle down someday or
like what
like what are your thoughts on that and
it's interesting because even like the
biggest like playboys and players still
most of them like wanted to settle down
at some point
um but
the interesting thing is like all these
guys body counts are probably in like
the triple digits right they all wanted
a girl with a low body count like a lot
of them said less than 10
even though they go home with like a
different girl every weekend so that's
it's like interesting because
i don't know and um also
like
they all also i mean this is like and i
think any girl knows this they all said
basically like they would sleep with a
girl that
like they would not
date like they would like like there was
even one night where one of the guys
says yeah like i was trying to get her
like out because she was not cute
um
do i think it was helpful to guys um i
think a lot of guys look at this as like
some blush on my nip what
um
[Music]
turn my phone over
no i have to the way it's like sitting
because otherwise
um
oh thank you for the super chat
thank you
did you at least get to approach anyone
to see if there's a different outcome oh
my god thank you for asking that because
this just reminded me
um
i i didn't approach anyone because like
i have a boyfriend so i obviously wasn't
gonna approach anyone but i did
i did
see um
i did see how much it helped
if i acted like i was friends with the
guy
like um if i like because a lot of times
i could see the girls immediately get
more comfortable if like a guy was
talking and i went up and said hi like
i'm i'm pearl um oh my gosh have you met
my friend and they'd be like what are
you here for and i'd have to think
i'd always say like oh i'm here with my
brother and like all of his friends and
so it kind of just seemed like i was
just with them and like oh isn't he so
great or whatever like talk him up
and
yeah that helped a lot thank you for
that point because i am going to put
that
in the video um
[Music]
it helps a lot
to have
a girl
a girl
that's like social proof almost
um
oh my gosh my battery's low
being introduced by a good person is key
friend of a friend
oh my god i gotta get
a charger
[Music]
okay
um
oh
and
wait can i plug it in here
okay
are we still dating yeah yay
okay
this is the benefits of the friends yeah
okay i think
i think that's such a bad advice they
give to guys it's like
don't
don't have female friends that are girls
because even if a girl puts you in her
friend zone like most girls if you have
a guy in the friend zone like they're
more than willing to set you up with
their friends like
um okay
yeah
yeah um
okay
do i think it was helpful um i think a
lot of guys look at these conferences
um
as a hail mary to change everything
um
i think
i think realistically
you could maybe
get
10
better
um
okay do i think it was helpful what
other put more questions in the chat too
because
this was a little bit ago so i'm just
trying to like
get my creative like
stuff flowing
because i'm trying to like put
everything together
um criticisms okay one criticism i had
was sometimes
my okay the one criticism i had about
the conference was sometimes the
the instructors like they're supposed to
stay out till four in the morning and i
feel like if i paid thousands of dollars
like i would want the instructor with me
the whole night but some of them would
go home at like two with like a
different girl
and it's like
these guys paid to be here
like set the girl up with your friend
and i think like part of it's they want
to like show off
but
wing woman or wingman oh my gosh that's
a good question
well there's pros and cons because
a win man if she has friends like your
friends can talk to her friends so that
like makes it a little bit better
um yeah i would say
it depends on the quality of your the
wing girl or the wing guy
um
yeah i would say it kind of depends but
i think like having girlfriends is like
a form of like social proof almost
um
is this really worth it or is it
something okay that's a good question
um do i think it was helpful
is this
really worth it
or is it something
you can do yourself
um i would say yes and no
um i would say it's something you can do
yourself but most people won't and i
like i think it'd be really good for a
beginner i don't think it's as helpful
for someone
it is good
for a beginner
but not as helpful for someone
when i'm just starting out
um
and
most people i don't think actually will
go through the work
of doing it in my opinion like
because it's like when you have coaches
there you have someone forcing you to
talk to these girls and like approach
them so like most of the time like
you're gonna get intimidated or scared i
would imagine right
but then you have like
someone forcing you to do it so i would
say that's like what you're paying for
um but i i think a lot of these guys go
in expecting to have like be completely
different but i don't
like i think it's gonna like with
anything getting good takes time
so
you know you're not just gonna go out
one weekend and be
a completely different person but you
might if you like
you know work hard while you're there
you might get like 10 better
um
criticisms um the guys teaching would go
home with girls
if i paid that much money
much money
i would be pissed
um
any other criticisms
my skin it's getting more clear but it's
also like breaking out
[Music]
okay what else i learned getting laid is
a lot harder for guys than i thought
um
even the relatively
attractive guys
had to approach
a lot of
girls um
um one of the guys was a really good
dancer and i think that helped him a lot
when approaching girls like
um that was like a really
good move i guess
um
what is my opinion on pickup i don't
promote that type of lifestyle but i
think the skills can be helpful and guys
that actually like want to find a
girlfriend
um i don't promote like picking up women
casual sex sleeping with a bunch of
girls um like treating you know people
like they're disposable um
but i think that like the skills that
they learn there can be helpful for like
both men and women like
i think
girls like want guys that know how to
talk to them so
am i doing school
no um
i'm like scripting a video i'm actually
going to end this because i feel like
people on my tick tock live are kind of
bored unless you guys are entertained by
this
um
okay
live just because i felt like
i was kind of boring them
robert you can't find a way
yeah that's what i that's what i think
too
like
um
you kind of have to like learn those
skills
to find a wife but i'm also saying like
i don't think you should spend your
entire like
free time doing that but
and i think that's why people pay for
the conferences because they don't want
to like spend all these hours just like
doing it
oh i have a question do women need game
no
no
oh i think game helps but you don't need
it
because i am awkward i'm so awkward
like oh my god i'm so awkward
and i don't think most guys won't talk
to me because i'm awkward
to be honest
just talk
any other questions come and like run
through this
i know
i went to a pickup boot camp i know what
you're thinking what is pika what is a
pickup boot camp and why on earth were
you there pick up it pick up
a pickup boot camp is where
pearly i don't think you struggle at all
you have a room full of guys watching
you now
um
okay i don't think four is a room um
but yeah exactly that's what i'm saying
like i'm awkward
and it's not hard as a girl um okay
i want you to pick up boot camp i know
what you're thinking
um
what is pickup well but the thing is
like what is girl game
let me know in the comments what do you
think girl game is
um pickup is is a boot camp where people
mostly men go to a location for a couple
of days and they're basically taught
how to get laid
i think class helps like as a girl if
you're classy but
like genuinely i think you're either
like born like raised that way i think
that's very hard to like
be taught
to be honest
how you flirt how you talk how you dress
yeah
okay i have no game um
oh my god ow
um
what's my opinion on female dating
strategy um i think that's a different
video
russian taught attractive women game to
spy on weak men in order to
and other intelligence agencies that
worked pretty well
did they have game or were they just hot
um
there used to be schools for this damn
oh my gosh okay um
you were watching the volleyball match
like it was espn
that was such a bad game though like
they were so bad
um
okay so why did i pick
has gone to a finishing school what does
that mean
i don't know if do i want to know what
that means okay why i picked john
anthony lifestyle
um
i have heard
mixed things about him
in the community
but when it came
it came to
getting women getting girls
john anthony
seemed to know
what he was talking about
he was talking about
there
is countless
pictures of him
with women in hotel rooms
hotel rooms
three girlfriends
finishing school is the female version
of pickup school i've never heard of
that
i want to google this it could be a fun
video finishing school
oh my god that's a real thing
oh an estranged concept to people
nowadays most of them have vanished
huh interesting okay
three girlfriend
yes three girlfriends
what's pick up oh i should do the
history of pickup in this video
what is pickup
and where did it come from
it come from
so i know there's mystery
hey hey
rsv
i think it was pretty big for a while um
i know a lot of stuff has been like
scrubbed from the internet
scrubbed from the internet
oh my god i'm so hungry
i already
ate this is why i'm losing weight it's
hard
okay why i picked a john anthony
lifestyle
um i've heard next thing about him in
the manosphere community
but when it comes to getting girls john
anthony seems to know what he's talking
about there are accounts countless
pictures of him with women in hotel
rooms three girlfriends and
and his blog
from over the years
years documenting
all he has learned about women
about
women
um
i genuinely believe
he knows
how to get laid
um
most of it um made sense to me um
he compares talking to girls
um
sales
okay so
so what is pick up and where did it come
from why i picked john anthony lifestyle
my goal
um
i my goal
so i wanna
so why would i go to this
oh my god is it 10 o'clock
damn it's 11 here
oh my god i'm so hungry
so
okay um
okay
um i wanted
initially i wanted to invite a guy um no
experience with women um
and document
so my initial goal was to invite a guy
that had little to no experience with
women and document his progress
throughout throughout the boot camp
camp
boot camp
and
come back
and let my followers
know how it went
but i actually had trouble finding a guy
that was
wildly acceptable with women
with women
that actually wanted to go
to go
um partially because i could not pay for
the floor
um randomly
i met a guy
who while i was using my friend talk to
him about this
um okay
oh my gosh i'm getting tired
oh my gosh i think this tea was like
hi
um
okay wait
we have a budding young scientist here
god i'm so hungry right now
can i make a smoothie
oh i'm so
i hungry know why
i'm literally like starving
and i like just ate
i get these like crazy hunger like
oh my god like crazy hunger pants
randomly
do you wanna have salmon and rice or a
smoothie
okay i'm gonna eat
and then i might go live in a little bit
um
but i might go live in a little bit if i
keep doing this but i'm kind of tired so
i might finish it tomorrow
but okay
okay bye guys